This episode of Dnews is brought to you by
BASF, THE chemical company.
Still counting your calories?
That's so 2014.
Hey guys, Tara here for Dnews - with one of
the coolest inventions I've seen in a very
long time.
A company called Consumer Physics just Kickstarted
the Scio - which is a molecular scanner that
can scan physical objects and give you a breakdown
of their chemical makeup.
It works by flashing a beam of infrared light
onto whatever material you're scanning, then
uses a built-in spectrometer to analyze the
light that gets reflected back.
The spectrometer determines the absorption
rate of the material - which is different
for every object - and then cross-references
that against a database of materials, to figure
out it is.
It then sends that data back to your smartphone
over Bluetooth LE.
So for food, you would scan an item, enter
the approximate weight of what you're about
to eat, and within seconds, you get a neat
little breakdown of the calories, fats, carbs,
and proteins in it.
Amazingly, it can also gauge the quality of
the food you're eating - so things like produce
quality, ripeness, and spoilage in foods like
cheese, fruits & vegetables, sauces, salad
dressings, etc.
But it's not just for food!
It also works on plants and medications.
For plants, it can analyze the moisture levels
and tell you when you need to water them.
And for drugs - the example they give, is
that if you were to order medication online,
from say another country - you could scan
it, to make sure it's legit.
Over time, the goal is to expand Scio to cover
just about any physical object - cosmetics,
clothes, jewels, plastics - even human tissue
and bodily fluids.
One day, its creators hope to see the technology
built straight into smartphones - which would
be amazing.
When it ships, the Scio will cost $149.
And they've already quintupled their Kickstarter
goal of $200K, with several weeks left to
go.
So if you wanna back it, head over to their
Kickstarter by June 15th.
And hey - speaking of great inventions, Discovery
Digital and BASF are teaming up once again
- to encourage kids to use their imagination
and demonstrate their knowledge of all things
science.
Children in grades K-8 are asked to submit
a 2-4 minute video about an educational and
creative science experiment related to chemistry,
sustainability innovation, technology, or
energy.
One Grand Prize winner will receive a $10,000
college scholarship, along with an iPad and
a Stuff To Blow Your Mind prize pack.
To enter, just submit your video to stufftoblowyourmind.com/science-awards
by May 23rd.
The winner will be announced June 6th, and
the winning video will be featured on StuffToBlowYourMind.com.
So get your submissions in!
In the meantime, if you have questions, comments,
anything you wanna say about this episode,
leave em in the comments below.
Otherwise, thanks for watching!